- "Les Parents", c'est l'enfance
de la majorité des Québécois,
Québécoises.
(inaudible)
- Vous dites entre vous là :
"Nous, cette émission-là,
tout le monde l'écoute."
Ce serait quoi?  OD. Puis,
les autres?
- Il n'y a rien.
- Vous nien?
- Dans ce cours de communication
au Collège de Rosemont, peu de
préférences télévisuelles vont
faire l'unanimité. Par contre,
la majorité des étudiants
reconnaissent qu'ils écoutent
et regardent beaucoup plus
de contenus en anglais.
- 85 % anglais, puis
15 % francais.
- 60 % francais,  20 anglais,
20 % japonais.
- Moi, je dirais 50-50.
- Moi, 40 % en anglais, 40 %
en espagnol et 20 % en francais.
- Honnêtement, 90 % anglais,
10 % francais.
- Ils vont sur plusieurs
plateformes et disposent
de plusieurs écrans.
- On a plus le contrôle de
ce qu'on regarde. Par exemple,
à la télé, c'est ce que la télé
nous offre. Mais quand on a
notre téléphone ou notre
ordinateur, c'est nous
qui peuvent aller sur Netflix,
sur Youtube. C'est nous un peu
qui contrôlons ce qu'on va
regarder.
- Personnellement, moi,
si j'écoute une émission
de télévision d'une demi-heure,
déjà une demie-heure, ça va être
long à regarder non stop,
puis en plus de ça, s'il y a
des pauses qui entrecoupent,
c'est sûr que je vais arrêter
d'écouter, je vais décrocher.
- Les séries québécoises qui
passent, genre, à la télé
régulièrement sont un peu,
genre, quétaines. Ça fait que
ça ne donne pas nécessairement
envie aux jeunes d'aller
regarder ça.
- Bien, moi, j'écoute du contenu
français, mais c'est vraiment
de la France. Ce n'est pas
du Québec parce que... bien
je trouve qu'ils rejoignent
beaucoup plus les choses
que j'aime.
- Une fois de temps en temps,
il y a une série qui sort, que
pas mal tout le monde a écouté,
que tout le monde connaît.
Dans un sens, il y a...
bien "Stranger Things".
CATALINA BRICEÑO, professeure,
École des médias, UQAM
- Il y a quelque chose qui a
changé très, très rapidement.
C'est même pas... c'est même
à l'interieur d'une génération.
On voit déjà une segmentation
énorme entre les jeunes qui ont
aujourd'hui 22 à 28 ans, puis
même les très jeunes enfants.
Moi... puis ça, c'est non
scientifique, mais ce que
j'observe c'est que le point
de bascule est vraiment
dans la génération qui est née
à partir de 2004-2005. Parce que
là, c'est la génération
qui est née avec les réseaux
sociaux numériques.
- Les séries québécoises leur
semblent aussi moins visibles
sur leurs réseaux sociaux.
- Je suis sur Discord: c'est pas
dessus. Je suis sur Tik Tok:
c'est pas dessus. Je suis sur
Instagram: c'est pas dessus.
Je vais en entendre parler si
je vais sur Facebook parce que
ma mère reposte, sauf que
je ne vais pas sur Facebook
parce que ma mère reposte!
Ça fait que ce qui va se passer
c'est que c'est pas visible,
c'est pas accessible, donc
je passe à autre chose.
- C'est l'accessibilité
vraiment. T'sais, si les séries
québécoises étaient sur,
admettons, Netflix ou "whatever
the fudge" que je regarde,
rendu-là, ce serait bien plus
facile.
MARIE-LOU BOUCHARD, enseignante
communication, Coll. de Rosemont
- Il y a une perte de référents
culturels communs, oui.
Notre culture s'effrite
au profit de la culture
américaine. C'est pas bénéfique
ni au niveau identitaire,
ni au niveau linguistique,
ni au niveau politique,
ni au niveau économique.
- Je sais qu'ils ont mis
des films québécois sur Netflix,
puis ça, c'est parfait parce que
maintenant, je peux... j'y ai
accès, puis là, je les regarde
toutes.
- Ce n'est pas parce qu'un
contenu est offert sur
une plate-forme numérique
qu'il atteint forcément
sa cible. Catalina Briceno croit
aussi au travail d'éducation
qu'il faut faire, comme
on l'a fait avec l'importance
de consommer localement.
- Parallèlement, on parle un peu
malhabilement de l'immigration
et tout ça alors que dans
les faits, c'est un enjeu
culturel, un enjeu socio-
culturel. Éducation-culture...
Éducation-culture... à la limite
éducation à la culture!
Ce qui manque, à l'heure
actuelle, le plus c'est
une vision cohérente.
- Des partis politiques ont
promis d'investir dans
la production d'émissions
jeunesses.
- Si vous écoutez des séries
americaines, je veux le savoir.
Le Disney Channel.
- Les promesses électorales ont
même fait du chemin auprès
de certains jeunes.
- Que maintenant, ils sont plus
vraiment beaucoup sur
les réseaux sociaux, comme
les chefs de parti. Comme
sur Tik Tok, je suis sur Tik
Tok, puis, je vois Québec
solidaire, ou je vois même la
CAQ. Je vois Francois Lego qui
me parle.
(rires)
Il me dit : "Ah, bien..."
- Le contenu anglophone
des réseaux sociaux a très
certainement un impact sur
le recul du français au Québec,
mais le retard des vieux
gouvernements à se mettre
au diapason des jeunes est peut-
être tout aussi responsable.
Ici Anne-Louise Despatie,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.